[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing newt scamander
ruby's hagrid aragog and how the
fantastic beasts and harry potter films
interlap more specifically we're going
to be addressing
one big question did newt scamander give
aragog to hagrid
newt scamander is a famous magic
zoologist
known for his popular book fantastic
beasts and where to find them
fantastic beasts is essentially an
encyclopedia for the creatures of the
magical world
and lists everything that you might need
to know about them
newt was able to acquire this
information through years and years of
research
i have visited layers burrows and nests
across five continents observed the
curious habits of magical beasts
in a hundred countries witness their
powers gained their trust
and on occasion beaten them off with my
traveling kettle
but newt definitely isn't the only
wizard that cares about magical
creatures
and the next person that comes to my
mind when i think of love of magical
beasts
is certainly rubius hagrid hagrid was
hogwarts groundskeeper and later
professor for the care of magical
creatures
a posting that introduces students to
all manners of beasts
hagrid grew up loving magical creatures
and it was actually his love of them
that ended up getting him in hot water
you see
when hagrid attended hogwarts so did tom
riddle which meant
that the chamber of secrets had been
opened students were being petrified
left and right but no one knew how or
why
eventually hagrid was framed for the
crimes when riddle alleged that the
creature
attacking students was none other than
hagrid's pet aragog
if you can't remember who aragog is well
shame on you
but for the sake of the video i'm going
to reintroduce you
aragog is an acromantula a race of what
are
essentially giant spiders acromensulars
are classified as a category
5x beast by the ministry of magic and
this
is for good reason it has been expressed
that the leg span of acromangulars
can be as large as 15 feet which makes
them a bit more intimidating
than your average house spider
additionally they have eight black eyes
thick black hair giant pedopelps which
they use to eat their prey
and highly toxic venom to add to all of
this
acromantulas are sentient and highly
intelligent
in the chamber of secrets aragog uses
his ability to communicate
by telling harry and ron where he came
from revealing
he was given to hagrid by a traveler i
came to hagrid from a distant land
in the pockets of a traveler the theory
spreading around
that's not my own is this newt scamander
was the traveler
that gave aragog to hagrid we know that
after many years of travelling
newt returned to hogwarts and we know
that he picked up many creatures along
the way
hagrid also attended hogwarts during the
timeline that knew to return to the
school
the 40s which we'll hopefully see on
screen in one of the upcoming films
this makes it very possible that newt
would have met the young half giant
and perhaps given him aragog after he
expressed interest
others have also pointed out that
because newt likely knew that he would
aid dumbledore in defeating grindelwald
he may have wanted to hand off aragog in
order to make sure that he was safe
who better to give him to than a gentle
half giant with an affinity for magical
creatures
what do you guys think of this theory
let me know in the comment section
below if you enjoy the content please
like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time
your wizard howery
you